knowledge basically creates a human
being once you have the base knowledge
about things you definitely feel
confident I am Bellanca ad
I am simply learned certified cloud
computing architect even after 15 years
of experience in the IT industry was not
happy I was not convinced with my career
path because I was not really getting
anything new to learn evolving a small
cities I couldn't grow much so I thought
that I should take a career break now
during my mid-career break I was looking
for some form of learning I was trying
to upgrade my skills so at that time I
found about simply done I put in a query
for simply learn and they contacted me
back I did not know what exactly to
pursue they advised me that because you
already have the basic idea of the cloud
computing so it would be better if you
learn more so that's how I went into
this course the cloud architect master's
course is a perfect blend of cloud
technology the training and protects I
offer learning path of cloud architect
masters courses pretty structured so
they start with the self-paced learning
material and after that you have the
live classes and at the end you also
have to go through examinations as well
as you have to submit protect so they
start with AWS tech essentials and after
that they have a dual fundamentals and
then later on they take you to the AWS
Solutions Architect and AWS system
operations so they are covering almost
everything related to the cloud
architecture
I won't end training basically helped me
to interact with other attendees within
the class simply learn trainer helped me
in a way that they actually created a
bridge between the technology and my
knowledge
after taking the course now I'm a
certified cloud solutions architect and
this course has changed my life the
biggest impact of the course on my
career was that I was able to get my
confidence back again as I'm working as
a freelance consultant so I'm able to
give more time to my family in the
biggest of all I am able to give time to
my eight-year-old daughter from being a
full-time employee he was living a
monotonous life doing the same thing
again and again to a freelance
consultant who is actually living life
on his own terms so that's the biggest
achievement I really have learning never
stops and I think my life is changing
over a period of time with my hard work
and all the help from simply learned
though Thank You Selina
[Music]